[Musique]
où
ça commence par la défense de m et
hamiti donc il s'est fait frapper par
l'autre et du combin
moi ce que j'ai fait je vous ai dit
d'arrêter ce qui faisait que se sait pas
après s'en est pris à moi ou il est
baisse à commencer par des petites
insultes il disait presque tous que ta
gueule conner fils de ou c'est pas
du tout commencé à dévier les miss et
acheminés directement sur moi comme ça
pour une raison sa beauté sa presque un
jour sur deux
à 14 ans arthur revient de loin en
classe de cinquième il a été harcelé
c'était dans le coin parce que les
preuves à il se met plutôt avec un peu
au fond est là ici via un prêt aux dons
qu'il voyait rien
il m'a frappé il m'insultait et on
faisait des menaces de mort
je me sentais mal j'avais pas très mal
au début mais après j'ai comme un bleu
ça sa part assez vite et ça fait quand
même très mal comme
[Musique]
sa douleur va dépasser les portes de
l'école un soir arthur découvre que
celui qui le harcèle a créé un groupe
sur snap chatte pour se moquer de lui
pour éviter comment le voyez message
passe à chevaucher un canapé
je suis monté dans ma chambre et j'ai
écrit
sur les réseaux aussi son harceleur
l'insultent et le menace de mort
quand j'ai reçu le message dans le nord
sur ce n'était pas très bien vu ton jeu
les parisiens dormir jusqu'à 5 heures du
matin
petit à petit arthur sombre j'étais pu
tout comme avant mais note baissée
chercher moins deux copains qu'avant
j'essaie de m'isoler tout ça parce que
chose avant est-ce que tu avais
des envies suicidaires
non
pas spécialement
muré dans le silence arthur s'isole le
déclic et vient d'un copain qui prévient
sa maman
ça s'est bien passé ta journée
t'as fait quoi aujourd'hui à l'école
rien
et avec les copains s'est bien passé
avec paul comme l'était pas
tu m'as envoyé un message pour me dire
écoutez arthur vit quelque chose de pas
forcément très sympa il faudrait vous
allez le voir mais la très rapidement
donc je suis monté dans sa chambre et en
fait c'est mon fils était dans un état
de stress complet en hurlent ils hurlent
et il pleurait il était prostré sur lui
même
ils savaient plus du tout été
complètement déboussolé s'il a commencé
à me dire bah pour moi c'est du
harcèlement je dis moi ce que tu vis je
me fais frapper quasiment tous les jours
je me fais insulter je me fais un timide
et je m'ai fait milliers là j'ai dit oui
en effet on est vraiment dans le
harcèlement
pour faire reconnaître les faits la
maman d'arthur constitue un dossier là
on a dû du screenshot
snap chatte qui reprend les différents
éléments on a également un
donc encore du snap chatte une voix la
menace de mort donc après on est des
vocaux également mais malheureusement ça
niveau qu'on peut pas les avoir donc
c'était important pour moi justement de
tracer tout ça est également là par
exemple on a on a les photos des bleus
chemin que mon fils avait un sur son
corps par exemple sur la jambe gauche il
avait 14 bleus et sur la droite il en
avait 18 juste sur les jambes ensuite
après ben là vous pouvez voir les cadres
des hématomes preuve à l'appui elle
porte plainte à la police et prévient
l'école
les faits ont été minimisés en disant
banon mais se passe absolument rien du
tout à l'école on n'a pas de trace on
n'a pas de ma chambre ma pas de ceux ci
mais ça se passe sur internet regarder
vous avez des captures écran est là en
fait je suis un peu sorti de mes gonds
j'étais vraiment très en colère nan mais
vous n'avez pas compris que c'est un
tout c'est vraiment un tout enfin voilà
est ce tout il passe par l'école la
partie internet je vais m'en occuper y'a
pas de soucis mais par contre la partie
à l'école je ne peux pas
la rentrée suivante arthur change de
classe le harcèlement cesse mais les
séquelles sont là pour moi c'était
important qu'ils aillent voir un psy
parce que on a beau dire c'est des faits
traumatisants des faits marquants touche
à son intégrité alors on a touché à son
corps aussi un il a pris des coups donc
ça laisse des traces salé ce pack des
bleus mais ça laisse aussi des séquelles
psychologiques et moi il était hors de
question qu arthur justement ils
vivent avec ça en permanence mais
[Musique]
di maria
bonjour arthur bienvenue une bombe et de
coûts' à toi je te laisse la parole
je me suis fait harceler coraux
quelqu'un
ou débat il m'insultait
et après il a commencé
à me frapper
[Musique]
dans les pois
je me sentais pas très bien j'avais pas
envie d'un recours
je vais
je vais vous au ventre
j'étais malheureux c'est tout ben oui
[Musique]
arthur c'est vraiment j'en veux dire un
portrait robot de ce que nous les psys
psychologues psychiatres
médecins traitants infirmières scolaires
ça c'est tous les jours
marie-anne plett et pédopsychiatre elle
voit des enfants harcelés souvent
détectée trop tard le décrochage
scolaire c'est vraiment le premier signe
est souvent ça arrive après plusieurs
mois de harcèlement
et ensuite il ya la baisse des résultats
scolaires et à l'absentéisme scolaire et
en parallèle il ya des troubles
somatiques vraiment très distincts donc
par exemple les troubles du sommeil il
ya vraiment la honte de dire qu'on est
agressée et donc là effectivement on a
des tentatives de suicide qui sont
[Musique]
qui se met en place mais alors qu'apple
signes avant-coureurs parfois
des passages à l'acte qui ont tué une
vingtaine d'adolescents en 2021 au total
en france près de huit cent mille
enfants seraient victimes de harcèlement
scolaire
félix mathieu le parquet de mulhouse a
ouvert une enquête pour harcèlement hier
après le suicide de dina dont on a
beaucoup parlé déjà harcelé par des
camarades de classe et sa maman a pris
la parole hier soir la télévision face à
ses conséquences dramatiques le sénat
créer une mission d'information
elle est présidée par la sénatrice du
pas de calais sabine van heghe
on peut pas dire que rien n'existe plus
dix ans les différents ministres de
l'éducation nationale qui sont succédé
prennent à bras le corps le problème
malgré les dispositifs qui existent
il y a encore des trous dans la raquette
on ne peut pas admettre que 20 jeunes se
suicident c'est une raison suffisante
pour que le sénat se penche sur la
question
des dispositifs insuffisant surtout face
aux cyber harcèlement devenu un fléau
ces dix dernières années 20 % des jeunes
de 8 à 18 ans on aurait déjà été victime
nos enfants à qui l'on offre des
portables en moyenne des dix ans sont de
gros consommateurs de réseaux sociaux
snap chatte tik tok instagram
65% des huit 18 ans et sont inscrits et
ils sont souvent livrés à eux mêmes car
les parents sont dépassés
4 sur 5 ne savent pas exactement ce que
font leurs enfants sur le net les
réseaux sont devenus un espace où tout
peut arriver moqueries insultes
exclusion des groupes et plus grave
encore le chantage sexuel
et le harcèlement scolaire qui
s'arrêtait avant aux portes de l'école
ne laisse plus de répit aux enfants qui
en sont victimes
pour mieux les comprendre la sénatrice
sabine van heghe est venu écouter ce
jour là arthur et sa maman
elle posé une question
n'a pas parlé avant que le copain lui
téléphone et puis lui disait arthur il y
avait des choses à son patron pourquoi
tu avais pas osé parce que non seulement
pas des menaces de mort
ou de la personne voyage qui me disaient
ne pas parler chine au vent ils allaient
venir chez moi on
le plante un couteau et tapageuse et non
plus en parler à des professeurs
on se rend pas compte de toutes les
étapes par lequel mon fils s'est passé
quand vous avez votre enfant qui se
menace de suicide et de prendre un
couteau et se trancher la gorge je peux
vous garantir qu'en tant que maman ça
vous glacent le sang et je n'ai pas
dormi pendant des jours pour m'assurer
que mon enfant d'aller me faire une
bêtise et c'est traumatisant et c'est là
qu'on se dit c'est pas normal qu'on ne
soit pas entendu là on a touché à
l'intégrité physique de mon fils et
l'intégrité psychologique moi j'entends
cette maman jeudi mais quel courage et
là quel courage a eu arthur aussi un
feuilleton de cet enfant et quelle
chance il a quelque chance il a aussi
d'avoir eu une maman qui s'est autant
investi j'ai vu dans des rapports qu'il
y avait aussi des des copies d'écran de
l'agression sur
sur snapshots et ça les enfants se
permettent de dire tout et n'importe
quoi parce que c'est que des mots en
fait c'est rien et puis du snapshots ac
face on n'a pas forcément de traces ou
n'a pas ce genre de choses c'est tu as
pris des mesures pour enrayer sa au
niveau de son portable un contrôle
parental comme je ne connaissais pas
toutes les différentes techniques pour
bloquer ou pour être informé j'ai
purement clamant en fait coupé snapshot
j'ai piqué son portable il rentrait à la
maison ses opus portable ou vente
utilisé le portable c'est quand je suis
là et je vérifie justement les
informations
supprimées les réseaux sociaux au lieu
de les contrôler comme la maman d'arthur
beaucoup de parents sont démunis il
existe des applications de contrôle
parental il faut encore les connaître
elles sont pas c'est pas mis sur la
place publique surtout pas les réseaux
sociaux se nourrissent se nourrissent de
tout ça plus on d'abonnés puis ils ont
participants mieux c'est pour eux donc
ils ont aucun intérêt je dirais à
combattre ça
il existe pourtant des moyens de limiter
le cyber harcèlement comme le numéro
d'appel 30-18 où parents et enfants
peuvent signaler des contenus
malveillants
30-18 bonjour
alors vous allez peut-être pouvoir me
dire mais en tout cas dans la situation
pour m'expliquer semblerait que ce soit
que votre fille soit victime de ce qu'on
appelle un chantage à la webcam c'est
quand deux personnes qui se connaissent
pas forcément commence à discuter car à
un moment donné il ya un échange à
caractère sexuel qui est effectué et
qu'ensuite la personne dont l'auteur du
chantage utilisent ce contenu pour dire
à votre fils écoutez si tu ne me plaît
pas tant d'argent eh bien je diffuse des
photos à tous tes contacts parce que le
but dans cette situation de chantage là
ça va être vraiment de bloquer tout
contact et tout lien avec cette personne
donc une fois que vous avez bloqué cette
personne vous allez pouvoir remplir ce
qu'on appelle notre formulaire de
signalement
que vous allez trouver grâce à un lien
que je vais pouvoir vous donnés
oralement
sabine van heghe vient visiter la
plateforme avec justine atlan la
présidente de l'association e-enfance
voilà vous êtes sur la plateforme du 30
18 qui est donc et verse toujours à tous
tu es donc hébergé par l'association et
enfants
donc là vous avez les cinq par les
capitaux tant qu'ils sont là ce matin
est le coordinateur qui est chargé de
faire les signalements c'est à dire dans
la masse de contact qui arrivent soit
par téléphone soit par chat etc il y en
a beaucoup qui ne m'ont pas
nécessairement générer du signalement
parce que c'est des questions c'est du
conseil où c'est des contenus qui sont
pas finalement illégaux et puis en veux
tu en as une catégorie après un quart
environ qui vont générer un signalement
ok du tout ce que vous pouvez faire dans
un premier temps c'est dire à votre fils
de m son instinct agrément privé notre
souci c'est que ceux qui ont besoin nous
nous connaissent et c'est vrai que c'est
toujours très frustrant quand on voit
des drames des choses comme ça qui se
passe de se dire mais mon dieu on aurait
pu aider cette personne à notre place
mais on aurait pu l'aider déjà faire
arrêter cette réalité qui est
effectivement monstrueuse quand on en
est victime à car souvent les victimes
se tourner directement vers les services
de modération des réseaux sociaux mais
ils sont moins efficaces
ils sont envahis en fait de signalements
qui vont
beaucoup occupé leur service de
modération mais pour majoritairement des
contenus dont il ya rien à faire donc
c'est vrai qu'ils vous priorise ce type
de partenariat avec des tiers de
confiance qui vont faire en fait d'après
modération en fait ce qu'on fait nous
c'est de l'après modération c'est à dire
qu'on fait comme un modérateur certes on
nous signale un contenu on regarde on va
identifier ça nous paraît illégal ou pas
et donc on va leur dire à ben et donc
nous ce qu'on leur amène à l'inversé
savent que 99,9 pour cent de nos
signalement à nous sont complètement
pertinent lorsqu'il ya des choses qui
peuvent vraiment supprimer tout ce qui
fait que pour ceux avec lesquels on
travaille depuis plus longtemps et de
façon la plus proche ils regardent même
pas les contenus polar signalis alcan ce
énième lyon ils vont supprimer tout de
suite tous les messages signés les paris
enfonce son outil dès qu'ils soient
publics ou même privé une découverte
pour la sénatrice c'est une grande
surprise il semblait que c'était
impossible impossible d'entrer et
notamment sur les messageries privées
aujourd'hui je découvre je découvre que
c'est possible
tout le discours que je tenais moi c'est
que les réseaux sociaux ne peuvent pas
ne veulent pas ne peuvent pas agir
aujourd'hui je découvre ici
[Musique]
quelques mois plus tôt la mission
d'information avait auditionné au sénat
les représentants des réseaux sociaux
sabine van heghe et colette mélot la
rapporteure avaient alors entendu un
discours bien différent
[Musique]
avez vous la possibilité de supprimer là
aussi des contenus voire de fermer de
tels boucle des messageries qui ont été
design if ans c'est très abstrait
anglicismes ans mais qui ont le privacy
by design c'est à dire que ce sont des
conversations qui sont privées et donc
du coup nous n'avons pas accès au
contenu de ces conversations le sujet
donc vous parlez là de la messagerie
privée et l'aspect privé est un vrai
sujet de fond qui n'est pas nouveau
puisque quand on regarde le code des
postes et télécoms l 32 3 sais tu n'as
pas le droit nous pouvoir y intervenir
puisque c'est du privé c'est comme un
message par sms après effectivement on
sait tous que c'est un endroit où aussi
les gens comme c'est privé peut faire
des choses qui peuvent être équipées m
illicites et c'est un vrai problème de
de fondre l'entourent a pas de solution
et qui d'ailleurs juridiquement doit
être regardée puisque le secret des
correspondances et quand même quelque
chose qui est fondamental je suis très
surprise de revoir cet extrait après
avoir rendu visite à l'association
e-enfance lors disco jean revient à dire
que pareil il y toujours polis et dans
le sens où il faut surtout faire croire
aux gens que la messagerie privée est
réellement privé qu'on ne peut pas y
intervenir donc voilà l'intéressé c'est
de continuer à ce que les gens utilisent
ces réseaux casse ce 30-18 qui existe
c'est ce numéro qui est la porte
d'entrée
pour signaler et supprimer ces contenus
en fait il faut que ce 30 18 et c'était
bien on l'a bien marteler tout le long
de notre notre mission il doit paraître
partout lors des auditions les
plateformes ont aussi minimiser le
phénomène de cyber harcèlement
sajoo images que vous voyez là un petit
drapeau qui permet de notifier le
harcèlement aux équipes de modération
qui tout de suite le regarde le retire
et agissent donc il reste très peu de
temps et on agit généralement dans
l'eure une des valeurs de snapshot c'est
vraiment la créativité et la gentillesse
et du coup on est vraiment intraitable
avec le cyber harcèlement on a une
tolérance zéro vis-à-vis du harcèlement
et pour aller un peu plus dans les
détails le ou qu'on soit le harcèlement
chez tik tok comme tout ce qui concerne
un comportement abusif le harcèlement
sexuel ou encore les menaces de piratage
et de chantage le cyber harcèlement
c'est explicitement mentionnés dans ce
qu'on appelle les standards de la
communauté ce dont je viens de vous
parler donc nos règles ce qui sur ce qui
est autorisé ou non sur la plateforme
s'est explicitement mentionnés c'est
interdit nous ne tolérerons pas ces
comportements notamment parce que nous
pensons que cela mais pas les
utilisateurs en confiance ils ne se
sentent pas respectés ne se sentent pas
en sécurité sur la plateforme donc c'est
explicitement mentionné voilà c'est
interdit c'est la plateforme peut pas
être plus clair à les entendre tout va
bien dans le meilleur des mondes donc
à la limite où est le problème où est le
problème pourquoi yat-il problème dehors
seulement si c'est si simple mais les
utilisateurs qu'on a peut aussi entendre
le disque pas si simple que ça auditions
n'ont rien apporté nous n'avons reçu
aucune réponse
convaincante et est adapté à la réalité
que nous connaissons en ce qui concerne
le cyber harcèlement des réseaux sociaux
qui se dédouane mais la prise de
conscience politique
elles avancent parallèlement aux travaux
des sénateurs les députés proposent une
loi pour lutter contre le harcèlement
scolaire et le cyber harcèlement la
sénatrice sabine van heghe veut profiter
de cette fenêtre législatives pour
mettre les plateformes face à leurs
responsabilités
nous proposons de compléter le
dispositif des obligations des
prestataires de services du net en
reprenant une proposition de la mission
d'information
il s'agit d'obliger ses prestataires à
présenter périodiquement à leurs
utilisateurs de courtes vidéos de
sensibilisation sur les bons usages du
numérique la prévention du cyber
harcèlement et les moyens pour les
victimes de réagir c'est un des
amendements notre groupe de de
contraindre les réseaux sociaux et
d'ailleurs ça reprenez une préconisation
de la mission d'information contre un
des réseaux sociaux à mettre des
messages informatifs sur les sur les
écrans
de notre sens pas compliqué de faire ça
quand on voit toute la pub qu'on peut
qu'on peut nous mettre qu'on peut nous
imposer sur les sur les écrans et
doit être possible de
commandes de lancer des spots
publicitaires
appeler ça un spot publicitaire
de prévention contre le
cyber-harcèlement
m'a été répondu que ce n'était pas
possible je pense qu on est tous
d'accord sur le fond mais les outils
nous petits français dans notre coin
c'est pas comme ça malheureusement qu'on
va le gérer on peut écrire dans la loi
qu'on a des intentions je pense que la
prise en compte réelle des contraintes
au niveau de l'europe y'a que ça comme
solution parce que les plateformes d'une
façon elles sont pas ici sont pas chez
nous donc comment on va imposer à
l'irlande un certain nombre de choses si
l'europe n'a pas de règles ou alors par
exemple je réponds à madame la
rapporteure bien sûr que nous attendons
une prise en compte de l'europe mais
nous avons le devoir d'imposer nous en
france aux plateformes de prendre en
compte cette cette question je vois pas
en quoi en quoi ça dérange et
d'imposer sa patte de placer sa dans la
loi
je vois pas en quoi ça dérange et à des
tas de choses dans les lois qui ne sont
pas appliquées
donc on le mettait au moins on avait une
volonté de s'y coller quoi
j'ai pas compris
[Musique]
pour sabine van heghe il faut agir dès
maintenant car même si l'europe prépare
une directive pour contraindre les
mastodontes du web son application sur
le sol français n'est pas pour tout de
suite elle entrera en vigueur au plus
tôt en janvier 2023
cet arsenal juridique va obliger les
réseaux sociaux à modérer les contenus
il s'annonce comme une révolution car
elle pourrait signer la fin de leur
impunité
d'ores et déjà la perspective de cette
loi fait bouger les lignes et oblige les
réseaux sociaux à s'impliquer sur ces
questions
c'est le cas d'instagram qui finance
depuis la rentrée des sessions de
prévention sur le cyber harcèlement
auprès des adolescents et de leurs
parents dans les collèges ya une panne
tous les jours au lit dit toi à toi tu
es une belle pomme toi tu es une bonne
pomme toi tu vas réussir toi c'est cool
et tout est l'autre côté il ya une pomme
tous les jours quand elle va parler on
va se moquer
tous les jours
on va lui dire qu'elle est moche qu'elle
est nulle et puis une petite ou
un petit coup comme ça
et tous les jours ce pom a va subir ça
le truc c'est que
extérieurement elles auront l'air
identique peut-être que même d'ailleurs
avec sa jolie peau de pommes à va
couvrir quelques trucs là point b
le truc c'est qu'en réalité si ces
pommes on les coupe en deux
elles seront pas du tout pareil
ça fait toujours ce bel instant de
silence là parce que ça a déclenché chez
vous une émotion qu'est ce que ça aurait
déclenché chez vous comme émotions là ça
vous fait quoi on voit qu'ils avaient
scellé mais il fait mieux que les 2
premiers reste physiquement ils restent
identiques et à l'intérieur ça veut dire
que lacombe l ai trouvée alors que celle
de la lé normal tu utilise le terme
normal c'est ça
la subit du coup officiel quand elles ne
démontrent pas m à l'intérieur c'est
là-dessus et c'est hyper beau ce que tu
viens de dire
en fait bas donc fabi liste de ne pas
avoir vu ce qui se passait donc je peux
avoir pu l'aider quoi
vous êtes en train de me faire la
transition mais tout seul c'est hyper
pertinent là quand on est pas la victime
on est un peu comme les harceleurs mais
juste comme ça mais je trouve que c'est
quand même hyper important d'aider les
autres quand ils sont en situation de
faiblesse
et c'est ça le plus intéressant parce
que tout le monde le fait pas tout le
monde le fait pas par réflexe et tout le
monde le voit pas sur tout la plupart du
temps ça m'a appris des choses sur sur
les réseaux sociaux des choses que je
n'avais pas encore et ça m'a aidé par
exemple pour deux mois fait ne pas me
moquer les gens parce que ça peut avoir
des conséquences sur leur moralité et
les rabaisser sans le savoir
financé par instagram le contenu de ces
formations est vérifié par l'éducation
nationale du lobbying déguisés mais un
partenariat assumé par le gouvernement
qui se mobilisent pour en faire la
promotion
on a tous une petite part de la solution
et c'est collectivement que depuis trois
ans nous travaillons sur ces
problématiques l'acsa sur la question
l'accès précoce des enfants et la
pornographie ou la question du
harcèlement scolaire par exemple et donc
pour la première fois nous avons mis
tous les acteurs autour de la table tous
les acteurs de la chaîne de valeur donc
oui les réseaux sociaux que vous évoquez
mais aussi les fabricants de téléphones
chacun a sa part de responsabilités et
doit contribuer à une solution pour
mieux protéger nos enfants
c'est un affichage sympathie pour le
gouvernement de dire je fais des choses
et puis je les fais à moindre coût mais
peu importe je dirais moi mon sentiment
c'est peu importe voilà
[Musique]
peu importe la méthode si le
gouvernement les réseaux sociaux mais
aussi les parents les enseignants et
tous ceux qui gravitent autour des
adolescents s'impliquent cela sauvera un
maximum d'enfants
et vous ça me met mal à l'aise à dire
mais
ou alors ça voilà je suis détendu est-ce
que tu peu inquiet a
pas il faut en parler parce que ça peut
aller très long
faut vraiment en parler parce que c'est
ça peut être très dangereux
[Musique]